the jurogan experience that always
pissed me off
why no i don't mean nick newell fighting
with one hand pissed me off but how can
you fight with one hand but you can't
fight with one eye
they told you you can't fight no you
can't you can't fight with one eye but
yeah how like i always wanted to ask you
this when was your vision first
compromise was it after the it was after
the vitor fight right it was the veto
fight that did it uh and i slowly
started getting our symptoms i was doing
this a lot in restaurants you know
restaurants are dark some of them i was
like i was doing this you know my
friends would be like oh he's doing that
thing again with his hands i'm like can
you see your hand there if you do that
so
people are just listening you have your
hand next to your face
moving your fingers around and you kind
of see it yeah exactly and then by the
end it was like right in front of me
there and i couldn't see and it was at
that point i called the doctor but um
i fought alan belcher
after the veto belfor fight and then as
i say as this was getting worse and
worse and worse i called the doctor and
said yeah you've got to detach wetner
they fixed that it redetached i got
glaucoma it was just just bad luck one
thing after the other anything that
could go wrong with an eye went wrong
um
yeah how did you get to the point where
you're fighting gsp like how how did you
pass this test with great difficulty
lying
cheating [ __ ] codes i [ __ ] lied
to so many doctors like i went to
england i was doing some uh
work for bt sport at the time dana was
trying to help me out because looks like
looked like i wasn't going to be
fighting you know so i went over there
doing some work for bt sport
and uh you know i was talking about
fighting again and i said well we want
to take you to a doctor of our choice
so i said all right cool whatever and
i'm [ __ ] my pants you know
and i i had to do this test where you
look into this thing and there's all
these lights you know and you push a
button when you see the light pop up and
i just [ __ ] get i passed it i just
[ __ ] guessed it
you just guessed it i guessed it and i
passed right and then there was another
one they took me to see another doctor
and i went in and this doctor was an old
indian guy lovely sweet man and there
was a guy in there like an old war
veteran who could hardly walk like about
100 and something years old very
eccentric old gentleman and this doctor
says i'm just going to walk this man to
the car go into my office make yourself
at home i might [ __ ] get in because i
walked in and the eye test was there it
was an old-school one it wasn't a
digital one it was like a triangle you
know
three sides to it and all you've got to
pass is you've got to have 2200 vision
to pass which is still clinically blind
but on the night test it's the big one
at the top and then the two underneath
it so still pretty big
so i'm like okay d b e spin it around c
d e so i remembered all three and uh the
doctor doesn't know that i'm trying to
cheat the test he thinks i'm [ __ ]
trying to check on my vision like a
normal person you know what i mean so he
covers up my bad eye first and he says
what can you see
go through it all very good and then he
doesn't move it round and he says okay
what can you see there and that's where
these couple of shitty acting lessons i
had paid off i'm like
d
[Music]
c
e
gets a little blurry after that doc if
i'm honest couldn't see a [ __ ] thing
and he's like okay you've passed he said
he said listen
um
you've passed
to fight he said but i wouldn't fight he
said because if anything happens to your
good eye you're going to go blind and
i'm like
oh yeah yeah um yeah you're right doc
yeah oh well i'll give it some thought
i'll maybe i'll talk to my family yeah
oh god what a situation right yeah and i
walked outside [ __ ] come on because
it meant i was back right but of course
then every time you fight you're still
gonna get checked by a doctor again
every time at the waynes you know so
that was always very very worrisome so
how did you pass those
they just didn't check very good
i mean i i had uh i had a code with
he always came in with me and i said
right because all they've got to do
because now this is a prosthetic lens as
you know
and
i did i only got this in 2018
um so without the prosthetic lens in it
looks awful do you know what i mean it
looks worse now than what it did back
then over time it's deteriorated and got
worse and worse
but i thought all they've got to do is
look at that eye and say all right how
many fingers can you see you know so i
said to pirilla so if he holds up one
finger you go
if he holds up two yawn whatever it
holds up three we just came up with
these shitty codes you know what i mean
but we never had to use it once because
i remember once the doctor when you
could see how that eye right i said yeah
yeah of course i can i said i've got all
the paperwork okay cool wow that was it
that was it that was it that was all
right sweet cool
yeah
very few people would have still fought
at one eye that's usually the price
where most people are not willing to pay
anymore yeah well i just moved to
america bought this stupid big house
that i didn't need i had a lawsuit going
on with my former management which was
completely fabricated the legal fees
were just incredible um
i just i couldn't quit i had no choice i
had to still fight you know
now life's great but back then i'm still
very much financially struggling
uh and yeah all i had well i had to
fight this court case this legal this
lawsuit and that was costing a fortune
and it's all i knew at that time
that's one of the craziest stories ever
that you won the middleweight title with
one eye
yeah and you won it by
lying to the doctors yeah i was
terrified i was terrified to [ __ ]
every time i fall i mean i don't want to
say too much
didn't it [ __ ] with your depth
perception though because that's one of
the things that they say
all the time like i'll go and grab that
bottle for example now i'm fine because
my brain's touched it so
i know where it's at i can judge it but
but the first time i miss i miss all the
time i'm always
misreading how far something is away do
you know what i mean right um because
you have the depth perception and
everything's in 2d and then sometimes it
can it can [ __ ] with me a little bit
sometimes i start getting a little
i can get a little blurry and like i
don't i get a little dizzy because it's
like sometimes it's only sometimes all
of a sudden i'm like whoa i can't
[ __ ] figure what about driving like
driving's fine but everything's on the
right side yeah you have to turn the
scene yeah it's next to you all the time
yeah if i'm changing length i always
have to give it one of those right and
turn really far yeah um and i'm always
hitting people in the face
like and it's always an old lady
oh no the amount of times because i'm
very animated right i talk with my hands
like for example i'm at a crosswalk in
new york city and i'm in the middle of
telling a story and i'm just i'm oh
oh my god i am so sorry
i've gone like that into someone's face
and it's always a little old lady
for some reason always you know and they
look at me like i'm the biggest [ __ ]
on the planet
i'm so sorry i am so sorry oh that's
horrible
yeah but um is there any hope for your
eye
no nothing there's nothing they can do
in terms of uh
repair
well
if you look at that wow it has gotten
worse yeah there's just nothing there so
wow um when i got this done which
changed my life in many ways to be
honest um i was just sick of looking
like that so you don't see anything out
of it no light nothing if if i cover up
my good eye and the lights go on and off
the shade of blackness changes
so it'll go yeah just ever so slightly
okay i can tell when the light's gone on
and off that's that's it and there's no
replacement lenses or anything that they
can do i saw oh i heard recently that
the
the they're putting in like robotic eyes
or something like that
yeah but i haven't looked into it yet
because you know two fake knees and a
fake eye yeah yeah imagine if it's
better
oh no i know could you imagine because
i'm [ __ ] back let's go
i'm back
one more for the road
[Laughter]
two fake knees stepping into the octagon
yeah yeah that would be wild fake needs
in a fake eye i think they have a an
electronic eye that they've created that
offers superior vision
and i think
i don't think i think it's just in the
testing phases now but see if you can
find that yeah jamie it's i'm pretty
sure
that it is superior to uh normal
eyesight and the way that it interacts
with the brain i don't understand i
don't know how it like interacts with
the optic nerves and the signals that it
sends
yeah no i'm sure it is better you know
with technology that they have one day
yeah no absolutely that's why i retired
though because the doctor said you know
and they always said you know if
something goes wrong with your good eye
you'll go blind